welcome ken today
we have a video i'm very excited to
watch with you it's the biggest and most
expensive house in the world wow
i've been looking at a lot of houses
i've seen a lot of really expensive
houses so i'm
i'm excited to see what they got for the
one you like watching expensive house
tours as well
this is not just me dude i'm officially
joining floor gang soon
you're moving all your stuff yeah like
we had to move up yeah we had to move up
the date to move stuff so i'm going to
be like here with just like a laptop sit
on the floor
record videos soon yeah i can't wait for
that
[Laughter]
appreciate it oh when you have to stand
up afterwards that's just pure pain
i look
okay so i found this video thanks to
cody code thank you sub
to cody thank you the thing is okay i
love watching these kind of videos
because i watch the architectural digest
ones but there are couple writers i
can't react to them
so i'm finally excited to watch these in
this episode we speak with nile
nayami the creator and visionary behind
the one
which he believes is about to change the
world
is he talking about the building i don't
know it sounds like it sounds like the
opening to the lower the rings right now
like the one ring
i'm gonna get some go ahead and say
niley's probably pretty delusional but
let's watch
the one is the largest house ever built
valued a half a billion
wow this better be good what kind of
[ __ ]
idiot buys a house for half a million i
have a billion sorry
half a billion right are there that many
billionaires in the world like
i don't know i don't know how long i
don't think
i wish there was one more honestly you
know
oh yeah guys become a member so i can um
about half a billion dollar house ballet
or
your california place in the world ken
oh yeah
is that the house it's where i've seen
that house it was on the
selling sunset it looks similar at least
half a billion for that
wow it's got a parking lot
wow that looks like some shitty trophy
from a video game
it's like this is the time that i got my
feet cleaned by the little fish at the
uh
at the nail salon
i wanted to commemorate it with this
statue
the pool is terrible there's two pools
double
three there's three pools we just had
the most
epic epic house tour in the history of
our channel i think in the history of
anybody's channel
what a guy wow what a
guy i thought i thought i heard like
ozzy osbourne there for a second talking
we just had like the greatest house tour
of
[Music]
he looks like one of those people that
go clubbing but never grow up
he looks this shirt was probably black
before he wore into the club and he came
out and looked like this
you know when you were younger going to
clemson it was almost that [ __ ]
old ass dude and i'm like why are you
here what the [ __ ] there he is
there he is in flesh and blood um i'm
sure you will agree
ah mr sleazebag that's the wealth right
this guy's about to they're watching a
drug deal go down i'm pretty sure
this guy did a line of coke right before
this
[Laughter]
a little bit on the shirt right there
what is that uh bruh
beanie and l.a get that [ __ ] outta here
my biggest pet peeve with l.a people is
when they're like oh it's a little cold
i
better put on a jacket
[Laughter]
they just love the idea of wearing a
jacket i'm like stop it you don't get to
appropriate this [ __ ] thing that we
have to wear we gotta die we're outside
in uk
i actually think i had a jacket in l.a
now i think about it god damn it
what we can do with the house what did
you mean tell everybody you look so
bored
i think that i have something very very
exciting and i believe
that i like the little paranoia of
looking over his shoulder
the cops are here
[Laughter]
the homeowners are going to come in in
any minute the house is called the one
bel air and my show is called
the one and between those two i think
that
we have the ability to really change the
world in a
very positive way
what how for one person
[Laughter]
in the house who are you changing the
world for right now
in a really positive way too i mean now
hungary and africa all these problems
it's also
thanks to the one house for half a
billion thank you noelle
how does this house change the world i i
i i will explain
so because of covet all of the
venues around the world have been either
shut down or dramatically
altered there is nowhere in the world
really where you can go
for a venue like you used to have like
a big boxing match or the academy awards
or the grammys or do you think they're
going to have the academy awards that he
can house what is he on where is he
getting with ace but
did he did he is he leading to that he
didn't build a house he built like a
convention center
is that i yeah what what difference does
it make the same
regulations and rules apply all right
judge before we know everything
to gather at staples center or mgm or
caesars palace or any of these other
places
but we have it now because this house
has the ability it just cures corbin
it has the ability to cure all diseases
you see rich people don't get coveted so
if you come to my rich house that costs
more than everyone else's
it just goes away how did this guy
get handled this project there's no
logic in that whatsoever
900 people in a
safe covent environment and
what is being created for this house is
a show
that is a show that everyone will want
to watch and identify with because
it stars me i live in the house and i
live in the house
people that i love and
crazy things and have crazy parties but
we also he's like
this house isn't going to sell so i
guess we got to film something i don't
know so he just compared this place to
like the staples center and all these
big places that can hold thousands of
people not code save
and then he's like but this is different
because we can have like 900 people here
and we have a show dude it's i'm
changing the world bro
i'm changing the world it's the one
obviously i'm delusional but that's fine
i wear beanie in los angeles it's
whatever the world
in so many different ways and one of
those ways we're doing it
is so many ways are creating gigantic
boxing matches right in the grass
gigantic
maximum 900 people though like
i never tell you that i used to like me
and my friends we would go out in the
yard and have like boxing matches back
in the day
this is you this is me if i ever get
rich right here okay i'm gonna go build
a stupid
like boring looking house that cost way
too much money just because of where
it's based at
this is like a flex it's like movies you
know like oh we
we made this much money in our movie in
the year 2020 when ticket prices are
like double what they used to be
we did it we set the record it's the
same thing with this dude's house
just the location alone probably cost
like way more than
any other house you know bel air on top
of the freaking hill
like imagine if you had to go and build
like i don't know like some
grand notre dame or something how much
do you think it would cost to build
today probably more than this dude's
house
you know probably you know it's like a
weird flex of just
but it's the one again
i just don't understand how people can
post this much but
i want to see what else it says it's
very entertaining boxers that you could
ever imagine and concerts and anything
that you could imagine that has a
pay-per-view event
leading up to the pay-per-view event i'm
gonna go ahead and let me say there will
never be
a pay-per-view event on this
it would usually be cheaper to get an
arena anyway it's not like there's any
difference
like what are you on about it sounds to
me like you may be having trouble paying
his bills you know
exactly that's what it seems like we
need this place to pay for itself
airbnb yeah and wants to market that in
this video
i am going to have a very very
successful show and i'm going to have
events like they used to have where you
have
energy and you have atmosphere
and that's what we're going to do right
here starting the next couple of months
right here on the grass it went from
like he's changing the world to like a
flex it's gonna rain money down
or go do it like we used to do it man
it's gonna be great changing the world
900 people at a time we have a flight
field of grassy here it's gonna really
make an impact he's talking like he
actually is the only one who has a
yard boxing event with the
biggest boxers that you've heard of
in your life with round tables around
the event where people are going to come
and they're going to eat
and they're going to have a good time
again in an event the way that it used
to be but
way better than it ever was because we
have the energy from the city
they have energy from the city what
no way they have like some sort of
electricity or
this is the one i mean no other house
has any of these
felix please tell me what this dude's
talking about because
it's kind of black face like what i
would love to speak with this guy and be
like so
how exactly is that different from any
other hat it's so
right okay
what he's got logan paul and jake paul
on the phone right now like dude let's
have some boxing matches up here you
know bro
right that's what it sounds like i'm
sure they could do it but [ __ ]
man so how exactly is this better than a
stadium then
because it's in his yard okay gotcha i
gotcha
all right understand myself down for a
front row seat
he just wants to be in on it yeah
they'll be 35 000 to 40 000 each but you
can ouch
listen ouch
even the businesses for delusional
people
selling delusions i love it
you know the the fight between
floyd mayweather and manny pacquiao made
seven oh my god how [ __ ] long do they
speak i want to see the [ __ ] house we
have a better oh this is the whole video
hold up let's let's watch the actual
house tour then sorry
listen to this dude talk as a whole
video in itself though because yeah
like this dude's obviously surrounded by
just yes man that's why it's so fun i
want to talk to this dude
i'm sure he's a great guy but what i'm
sure he's a great guy
i'm sure he's a great guy just kidding
that's the most [ __ ] thing i've ever
heard you say ken
look he's got a lot of money okay i
gotta like him tell him
i'm sure he does a lot of possibly a lot
of uh
he's changing the world man how can you
not like him
35 000 a ticket at a time at his house
that he paid too much for
and now he's got to make some monthly
papers no one's ever going to buy that
house because if you
if you had to spend 500 million dollars
in a house
just look we haven't even done the house
tour yet but just looking at it you can
build something better
i promise it does it doesn't look great
but i can't wait to see this [ __ ]
house at last oh my gosh
there it is wow there's the
the fish foot thing again the pole isn't
even dug down
i gotta go off a ladder to swim
is the most epic of epic videos
it is a hundred and five thousand square
feet
it is called the one and what gets
better than that we
are with the one the one
niall who is right behind that hasn't
built this
and he is just an incredible guy
i can't keep saying i'm gonna no cameras
no that is
before in its entirety ever ever ever is
that correct that's right so this is the
first
view so we got a uh
that that opens into itself he
completely ignores this dude i love it
right i i just looked it up you know
they said it's the biggest house in the
urban world
yeah biggest houses in the world it's
number nine
oh so you look yeah fact check this
[ __ ]
you gotta have google next to you
wherever you're not walking to this guy
i'm like number one let me check that
out for okay
oh it's in the urban world right now
actually actually there's a freaking
skyscraper building that's like 400
000 square feet it's huge jesus christ
all right never mind they lied about
that too it's not the biggest nerve in
the world
okay that's kind of cool biometric we
have the latest technology
yo it's biometric i'm so sure
i have a billy here you go biometric
what the [ __ ]
i mean that's kind of cool biometric man
come on
guys i have never been in this house
before this is the first time walking
through the door
adam has never been in this house wow
and i don't know
thanks for clarifying that i don't care
let me show you over here so we'll come
and go this way this is uh this is the
entrance
where do i dump my shoes and jackets i
won't
i'm wearing jackets and beanies what am
i going to put up there's just a bunch
of marble in space
like where's the actual what's the point
of this this is
the personality i need some personality
in this house where's that
maybe maybe this is the dude's
personality
do you not see this thing in the middle
it's
oh we have the sculpture done original
for this house this artwork
michael phelps it's called unity and it
was they got a michael fam
sculpture no way well this doesn't do
sculpture
no [ __ ] clues it turns 360 degrees
eight turns
360 right okay i got this phone it
[ __ ] turns there
bro
3d what the [ __ ] dude the sculpture
looks like a piece of plastic man
what the seating areas in the house this
foyer
is a true foyer it's like an art gallery
when you have so much art i mean i guess
i'm looking at only art
it's like oh you mentioned it
let me show you over here love that rich
person life
[Laughter]
oh man this dude's even got like a swag
walk to man he's walking like he's got
his back he knows what he's doing
a two-story office with an office
balcony i have to ask you a question do
you get lost in here
i don't i mean and for me it doesn't
even feel big anymore because i've done
it so many times but you know
that office is awful what the [ __ ]
the house space is just like vertical
like up
yeah the room is just tall ceiling
congratulations like
i wouldn't feel comfortable in this
office it feels way too big i mean just
imagine the echo when you're trying to
record
honestly i would hate this office i know
that's just me but i
still don't think it looks good 10 years
in the making right 10
years december 2012 was when i first
bought this land and um
and we've been pushing ever since and
this this office is the only room in the
house
the house is surrounded by water this is
the only room in the house that we just
said
another tangent about something else
it's the only room in that the view is
terrible too
like yeah i'll just say you can get this
office in like any city you just like
rent
an office space in a building and you
have it with a better view like
but this office you'll see every single
wall in this office touches water so
it's like it's floating look how dirt it
is it looks that's
like if that's what it is now can you
imagine where's the water
there is water this is very light you
see here the edge
but you can tell how much gunk it's
collected it's like you don't you're
good
they gotta have some things happen so
they can afford to clean it okay yeah
it seems like they need a boxing event
can you should set it
up oh my god out in the yard
i'm six foot two how high are they okay
that's a [ __ ] thought
there's probably 24 feet how do you
reach how do you really
get a balcony in your office so people
can like go over the edge and like peek
on you while you're working or something
[Laughter]
i love this how you have too much
storage when they literally like okay i
don't know what to put okay a bus yeah
maybe another bus
okay a bus a bus a bus a bus
this is our kitchen right now like we
have very tall
shelves in our kitchen like too tall for
us to even reach so we just have like a
plant
on each one like like one we don't have
to water like all right
you just you gotta just sit up there and
just live your lives because we're never
you can relate to this i see how it is
spectacular have you ever seen
an office with a balcony i have not i
actually noticed that i thought yeah
and there's probably a good reason for
that because why because
why would you need that in case you need
to look over the office
if anything in the office you want to be
private and then not interrupt that and
not have people
having a [ __ ] balcony where they
throw yo-yos down i don't know what
i wanted to do there's not even a door
to this office like
anybody can come in we have an open door
policy in our office here you know
yeah you're right it is impressive right
it's a big-ass office but it
who wants it and the price i think
that's the context right
i can't just say this is awful the whole
thing is set up for people to
do what we're doing to it right it's
like i spent a crazy amount of money
on stuff that nobody actually wants it's
so cool but we're like no it's not
who wants this yeah be critical about it
you know
i don't i don't feel bad about making
one this guy's house because it's awful
okay good
and he's not like you find it like the
plaza hotel in new york where you could
have multiple meetings at the same time
but it was very important for me that
the house feels comfortable and warm
which that's why i did the use of like
it definitely does not
warm suede wallpaper oh that change that
changed everything for me now
what do you mean warm this is the
coldest house i've ever seen
is this not the fourth season but who
wants to live
like it's a four things you're never
gonna sit in that can that couch looks
like it would hurt my back just sitting
down on it but also
why what are you doing the cat mary said
this to me the other day
when i saw that was looking at expensive
houses just for fun just like
the problem with big houses is they just
look like hotels and this is exactly
what this house looks like it's just a
big
it looks like at the hotel i'm right
yeah yeah there's no personality to it
it's just a hotel i'm fine with it
not having personality because you want
to sell it so you don't want it to be
too
do you spend this much money on a house
do you want to sell it you think he
built this to sell it
who knows i have a backyard with a view
of the entire la basin and the ocean
and one acre of usable space which does
not happen
anywhere wow what the show is i don't
care what the [ __ ]
oh my god that's the worst flex i've
ever heard in my whole life
we have a whole acre of usable space
that which we could have literally
anywhere else in the world
for a fraction of the cost but it's in
la and we have a view
of the smog filled polluted city
wow congratulations i like how the
backyard has
nothing it's just grass you can't sit
out there there's something
you can't do anything it's disgusting
this is a moat
and the reason that we did a moat here i
want to know
where there is not a moat you see the
glass rail yes so in order to have this
free
view to the city we had to put the glass
below which we'll go to
but so below we have probably the
world's most expensive running track
it did cost a lot of money but it also
gave us the look of no glass railings
which we'll go down there spectacular
i want to see it he keeps explaining
everything this is real grass and i'm
gonna walk on it
real grass and he's gonna walk on it
thank god he paused for uh tension there
i mean
all right here we go i'm not are you
ready at this
views
walk on the grass i can't wait i like
how he stopped like all right guys i
gotta make sure
real grass here we go there you go how
about that look i'm on the grass guys
[Applause]
you know i have astroturf in my place
right yeah
yeah and it's the [ __ ] greatest
you don't have to mow it everyone makes
fun of my astroturf
but you know who doesn't have to cut the
graves this guy
it's the best it's like watching people
that are too rich
like is this real grass now about to
step on and not on a golf course
oh my god we don't have a real grass at
our houses because
we're rich in murano italy
and they always say italy it's always
like oh this is stone italy
and love italy i'm like what's up
this artist was nice enough to make this
for us
and that's so nice and because they
wanted to be involved in the one but
it's turned into something so much more
because
my ex-wife do you remember at my wedding
there was this giant glass
things in the building yeah it's so ugly
and they were like they didn't tell us
those were gonna be there and they said
you can't photograph them because
they're copyrighted but like they're
in our face and we don't want them there
to begin win oh
god sculptures are just tacky dude i
don't like it
my favorite part about this guy so far
is that he never finishes a story
like he tells half of a story and then
like goes off into another one he's so
uninteresting i can't i'm just zoning
out when he speaks now
it was a whirlwind relationship i met
her during colvin and
no i don't care about your relationship
dude maybe it will still at the end i
don't know but this is a charity that we
have called wings of angels and this is
going to help
children in third world countries
through the arts because she is a
well-known
actress and singer in argentina and she
i'm waiting
for a very tough life in cordoba and she
wants to
be part of the solution of changing the
world and one of the ways we're gonna do
this here
is through this charity uh wings of
angels and it's going to build housing
what the [ __ ] are you saying i don't
the sculpture's going to change it by
building houses
here listen this is [ __ ] dude third
world country children to learn
through acting and through singing
that's remarkable
that's remarkable and it's spectacular
what does that have to do with a
sculpture
it's like he's making it up he's like on
drugs he's like all right guys
this g fuel i'm gonna drink it and it's
a charity and in other countries
they don't have and
and i got a um uh my dog is like the
most expensive dog in the world but it's
changing the world
through uh video gaming and everyone can
access a video game
so it connects the whole cyberspace with
electricity and pipe diameter crypto
currencies are going to
be changing the world and uh like dude
just finish like the fault
yeah it's blown glass it's the finest
blown glass there is and this is
same thing wow amazing i know italy is
famous for blowing glass well i'm back
on the grass guys
fine this is like all the grass again oh
wow
well i'm back on the grass guys i picked
out every single thing of this house
every paint color every stone every tile
i worked with furniture companies but
you know i picked like
all of this was all my idea like to keep
it warm and supple
it's so warm you're right i'm i'm
sweating in here
it's like such a cold house dude when
are they going to show us something
actually like interesting in the house
yeah it's so far not impressed not gonna
lie i am overwhelmed you've never seen
me overwhelmed in a house before
i am overwhelmed what are you
overwhelmed by
the lack of anything in it i guess i
think there's six elevators
all of my flowers are artificial but you
could never tell
right i thought they were real you don't
need to worry about them
staining and dropping that's good he he
has to worry about his
uh costs at this point and you don't
need to worry about
sustainability spectacular
sustainability with flowers
you mean ecological plant-based
it's bad for the environment is what
but plastic is better okay dining room
we have one of two wine cellars here
this is not completed yet but this is
the this is the one
or bigger so these are all for the large
format wines
and it's all temperature controlled i've
never been in here before
rich people love wines all these rich
people has this
just uh gotta have that giant wine room
right
i remember watching jenna and julian's
house and they have this giant like
wine thing and they literally just use
it as a room for their dogs
which is probably what we do too it's
like can you get a house that's nice
we're like
needing a [ __ ] wine oh well probably
just me
you're not a wine drinker here all the
way up
whoa how do you get up there you have to
use a scaffolding
a rolling ladder these are the best okay
there we go
that's what you need you need someone
you need someone drunk trying to get
another beer on the rolling ladder
climbing up in your house
and wine do you need there's 20 chairs
around this table
so we have another there is another
artist all these were made overseas
with with our designs i would feel like
such a [ __ ] chump
if i bought this place i'd be like what
the [ __ ] did i idea
anyone would fail oh this magical art
piece i got here the rings that are
connected ah
yes you know what we could change the
world ken half a billion dollars spent
to like a good
cause right it's about sustainability we
need to make a place we can go out in
the yard and have boxing matches at 35
000 a ticket and then my ex-wife is
going to do some charity
and then she's also an actress but maybe
we can get back together but also but
her best friend's
cussing mary is really into these
sculptures
but you don't realize how big they are
even though you can see them because the
house is big and speaking of big
you know i'm pretty cool myself uh
have you noticed i'm gonna be a show i'm
interesting there's people around me
do you know what else is so spectacular
you look either side of the house that's
going to be 100 yards away from us
and the views outside the windows wow
what are you doing nothing there
what a view amazing wow luckily for us
we're exactly framed of the getty that
is the whole getty right in front of you
this is another way we have two power
rooms here
may we take a peek sure all the powder
rooms have total electric toilets in
them
greetings okay i respect this all the
doors
i should be there that's the coolest
thing
best thing so far and they brush through
it
wow that totally just pulled his own
seat up holy crap
what is going on here look the house
isn't finished man don't they they need
to have some events they can finish it
they got the the painters tape on there
all right what the [ __ ] is this zero
electric so you push the button they all
open automatically
this is butler's pantry this is really
cool
it's like what can i see this is really
cool this is the smoking room the cigar
room and i did special ventilation here
i don't smoke cigars but um i got a room
for it
it has all vintage playboys
oh how cringe dude vintage playboys
uh a whole wall of it nice
wow they stopped their issuing playboy
now due to coving
yeah all right sure it wasn't dude
because people could just you know
get all that for free on the internet
now no no it's cool with that really
oh yeah they were thriving before i mean
come on
how does it feel to sit here now now
that it's almost complete
honestly yeah can you cuss
um exhausting
i i can imagine i mean like really
what the [ __ ] how does it feel to live
here now that you finished your house
exhausting he's really selling the house
to me i can't
i can't rest here man look at these
couches man yeah it's so cold in here
why the [ __ ] dude oh god we're never
gonna get through this video again jesus
christ let's skip the cigar and go to
art gallery
whoa look at that red different shades
of red dude
what the [ __ ]
you can sit and look at the red they put
benches
so you can look at them right lady i can
stare at the red all day
art's coming soon okay
punches could i just get
lost in the color
he hasn't built a home he's just built
like public spaces
yeah and that's why he realized like
[ __ ] what do i do no one's gonna buy
this i gotta
events the one this is one of the many
many many kitchens
but we have a a a main kitchen at the
lower level
the main kitchen no this is probably no
one will ever use
um what's the point all that
[Music]
i've never heard someone say that no one
will ever use this
then why does it exist
like i can you know
i got two places at my house that i've
never that i never go into right
so i can i can i can feel this a little
bit
i got a whole flat above my garage that
i'll never go into you can rent it out
i don't know i don't know i don't want
people living in my house well i mean if
i was this dude i would need to rent it
out obviously because he's hurting
changed the world that's 35 000 a room
man
cool things like it has a top brewer
here and
top drawer if you have no way dude i
actually like seeing that cool stuff in
the kitchen i hope they have some
me lay coffee machine in your healthy
machine right no but this is static
[ __ ] what are they called whatever
those cameras are
he's got a good grip is the coffee
machine the whole coffee machine so this
has an item oh yeah look it looks
working man you can make every kind of
coffee
tea anything you want but the cool thing
about it is this is the setup here so it
holds
the milk and keeps it cold so you don't
have to fill the milk up like in the
melees
and then it grinds it's a lot of work
this does everything you don't have to
descale you want to do anything you just
touch on your phone
cappuccino and other than having a cup
come up can't we see it then
i i'm lost for words i mean
it's absolutely terrible what a tiny tv
for that such a
big look the tv is huge okay you just
don't understand how big it is with your
eyes
okay can they go for something bigger
with that
giant they're like a product projector
or something yeah yeah
wait is that this is the latest
technology this is a tv the speakers are
going on the right why is it big tv
there
left but there's no frame to it there's
no separation it's just one screen so
let me stand in front of it so you guys
can see how small this screen is
uh and this is one of the can we see it
can we
how does it i like how they mismatch the
size of it too they build it
like what the [ __ ] yeah there's seven
total swimming pool water features total
this is the main pool
it has seven in the wheels three sides
wow this is a hot tub
and beyond this i'll show you what we
talked about earlier this is the running
track
this is the running track
well i can't wait to run there or you
can just you know
run here no no
[Laughter]
you could fill the tank of a car is that
the running track too
run out before you get to the end of the
house that's how long it is i mean how
many people is this hot tub for now
i'll let you know soon that's the
greatest answer we've ever had on the
channel
this is the outdoor living river where
are they simply for this douchebag
this is really nuts over here this is
like a wolfgang puck
barbecue oh like
like what well oh another kitchen do you
think they'll ever use this one
no probably not you know look at this
no normally what are you like they'd be
awful to cook in this what the [ __ ] this
is this is just an industrial kitchen
they have these in the back of
restaurants
look at the cabinets oh what could be in
them
cabinets what giraffe anatomically
correct giraffe skeleton
it's awful why
that's a nice giraffe sculpture but uh
is it anatomically correct though
um is it proportioned correctly oh it
isn't
get the [ __ ] out of here every light
that you see is custom because they
don't make lights this size
so that's kind of the things you never
they don't make lights that big ken
never
never done what is the other path what
what am i not understanding about that
sentence what the [ __ ] did he just say
they don't make lights that big they
just don't that's huge
i got i got this light back here in my
background right now that's freaking
like that
don't look this way just look at this
way to the right and don't look at any
of this just come straight
down to the left put your hand up all
right wow okay i'm walking on water
literally so this is literally
nice from the street right to the
nightclub so
if you want to have an event only not in
your house you could have valet from the
street
they'll come up here and then i'll show
you the nightclub
you don't want a nightclub in your house
that's a terrible
terrible idea who wants that [ __ ] why
check their ide right there
this is the nightclub look at this
should i do the reveal
okay here's the reveal so here's one of
them i recognize the color
of the house here's one of the most
technology
forward televisions with no you can see
there's no bezel on it it's just one
piece
and everything in this house you can
hang out is your creation
your ideas well paul mclean was the
architect but everything in this house
was generally all of my ideas and it's
starting to make sense now
it seems like a teenage dream like oh
well let me sick if i had like a
nightclub in my house
and then all the people could come by
and i'd be the coolest because it's my
house
and i would have like sit in the water
and have pipes hanging out on the sides
for
some reason so cool i like how you said
that
too he's like you know the architect was
actually this other guy but yeah
generally it's pretty much me you know
architect
two percent maybe one point five me
did the whole thing but i paid for it
you
it know on me i'm a genius brilliant
step here for a nightclub too right
yeah that's all about it you're gonna
get sued
in no time having a nightclub at this
place i watched the documentary of the
guy
trying to build the biggest house have
you seen that no but i bet he had a hard
time
well that's the thing it's really good
because the crash of
was it 2007 or 11 when he was trying to
build a biggest house and he was flexing
about it and then he lost all his money
and he made money in a scummy way too
which is whatever but
the thing is at the end of it you're
like no one would want to trade places
with this guy he's such a [ __ ]
terrible person terrible doesn't care
about his family and he just built this
giant house that he's never gonna be
able to finish
and it's just awful yeah like everybody
watching this video right now
is just like you know what i would do is
not spend all this money
on this house and just exactly do
something else
exactly it's so stupid everything is
precision
it's just it looks so wet
it's so amazing they put them together
they don't even look like expensive wood
or anything it's just plagues
and i've walked around a lot of these
places and michael you can attest to
this
some of the big modern houses you don't
feel like you could ever live there
they just just like this one do not
[ __ ] this and say that this is not
one of them
do not say that [ __ ] because you are
[ __ ]
smart as crazy as this is so cold
yeah because they have a slightly felted
wallpapers on one
tiny column get the [ __ ] out of here it
feels so
livable yeah it's beautiful and it will
be livable and you know what once i put
in like
what it where where where do you live
they have a kitchen that you never use
they have two giant sofas next to each
other you don't know which one to do
what the [ __ ] do you do on the grass
who would use that our face what do you
mean
you all said it looked like a hotel it
all looks like a hotel lobby in the
nightclub are you gonna live in the
nightclub
like a staircase in a museum see it's
turning now
oh wow oh there we go
okay we're back
[Music]
it's turning now what
have a mirror no get out of here
no what you can watch yourself no wow
no way dude
poor toilet thought they were there for
a pee debacle
you can sit and look at the people
working that's what it's for
why would you sit there well you see
it's like it's like the zoo right like
rich people a lot of people don't have
to work anymore so it's really nice
to come and be able to observe someone
doing the job
hey guys how are you down there sick
absolutely sick
yeah being scared no woozy
you can reach the top shelves from here
so this is the first living room
but why wait what are these walls wait
suede
are they making making fun of me what
the [ __ ] are they saying suede like uh
it's a material
and it gets ruined if it gets wet so
yeah someone's going to spill the drink
on the wall and mess up his suede walls
oh well it's a good thing they don't
have like a nightclub or anything in
there
the staircase going up can we pop in
yeah come to this one i'm sure you're
the best troll okay these are the best
two because
this guy wants to get this that [ __ ]
overweight
is it the best it's overwhelming it is
it's it's truly overwhelming
it is so wow
wow do you hear that in the silence you
can hear like the alarms going off of
like
the sirens i didn't hear it no i didn't
it's great
wonderful you don't hear it as soon as
all this happens but look at the battery
them all the same all the secondaries
yo they have a bathtub dude i love the
all the glass window you can like just
watch everybody be naked you know
take a was great oh shower god
so this is the kind of house you're
looking at and when you're moving ken
hell no come on absolutely not
but here we have a putting green
but of course what would it be without a
putting green why wouldn't you have one
a lot of houses have this now
did they just say they spent millions of
dollars just to like put their names
in units yeah so they can put the
green here because it's better ken it's
better very hazy it's usually never like
this you know
you mean this this is this is what it is
always in l.a it's always like this
what are you talking about this is like
a normal day in l.a
wow wow i can see the reservoir
with this [ __ ] budget and this land i
understand it's a
valuable uh area to live in they could
have done something so
much cooler but they went with the
dumbest generic
least practical things i have ever seen
and just listening to this guy talk a
bunch of
mumbo jumbo biggest lights
it's just so boring i'm done [ __ ] this
guy
what is that top garment saying oh buys
plastic to avoid waste
yet has a whole pantry in kitchen bigger
than my whole house
it's more sustainable the perfect view
of smog
[Laughter]
i'm all about voting base so i put six
elevators in my house
let's go well that was uh
a whole trip i'm not watching part two
[ __ ] that
yeah screw it i think we pretty much
first
pretty much solve it yeah it all looks
the same
smash like if you wouldn't buy this
house check out ken
subscribe links everywhere become a
member today so that we can build
something better than this and show it
off to you
that's smart that's smart buy g fuel as
well
thank you